hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of the 2018 candidates tournament here
we have another Russian brawl after that
game district versus Kramnik in the
previous round here we have Kerrigan
versus Kramnik and interestingly they
they go for for the same opening but
kirkin decides to take a different
approach and move for and then later
really surprises Kramnik with a certain
move so before we before we start with
this game here are a couple of photos
from this round here is kramnik making
himself comfortable here here we have
also a photo of kramnik dwelling under
position and here we have kurakin at the
moment as he pushes h4 I showed this
photo now as dh4 idea comes rather soon
in the game so let's see it
we have c4 the English opening east six
the alien core defense so the the same
approach he had against the Greece chip
in the previous round Knight to c3 d5
and d4 again transposing into the Queens
gambit the client and here we have
Knight to f6 in his game against Greece
should wish to continue Knight f3 and
then we had the immediate c5 here we
have C capture Sun d5 the exchange of
variation of the Queens gambit declined
Knight capture Sun d5e for now Knight
captures on c3b captures on c3 and now
c5 rook to be one Bishop to e7 Knight to
f3 and castles by Kramnik and here this
is the moment h4 was played here we can
check it out one more time so that's the
h4 move and here chromic played see
captors on d4 see captors on d4 and
Knight to c6 and here Kerrigan pushed
h5 and here you have to decide what to
do it's it's definitely not not in
everyday position and here took Kramnik
22 and a half minutes to decide on his
next move and obviously complete juice
to play peacefully with h6
you could maybe play b6 and
later defend against this would Bishop
to f6 but chromic decided to go for the
very active f5 after 22 and a half
minutes so Corrigan grab that phone he
captures on f5 Queen to a5 check this
was the whole idea
Bishop to d2 blocking check and now
Queen captures on f5 and Bishop to c3
better to c3 is definitely the strongest
move by Carrick in here it's hard to say
if Kramnik anticipated this the idea is
that if you go for something like a rope
to b5 which seems to be a lot more
active after Queen g4 Black is perfectly
fine here still this point is not under
a is attacked twice still White has to
deal with this
so after this Queen captures on a5
Bishop to c3 now h6 by chronic and
Bishop to d3 now also the idea of Bishop
to c3 making room for the Queen to
defend the bishop on d3 Queen to g4 and
here the g2 pawn is attacked so Kerrigan
goes for King to f1 castling here was
also possible but then you have to give
up the h5 pawn and it's a different it's
a totally different game then but what
is still ok even if he castles but
Kerrigan goes for King to f1 and here
again we have a lot of ideas here for
chronic he can go Bishop to f6 he can
continue to develop with b6 Bishop e7
maybe a lot of ideas here but he plays
d5 and E 5 is is a really forcing move
so something something will definitely
happen here and capturing doesn't really
give white anything so Kerrigan pushes
d5 which was probably expected by
chronic chronic pushes efore here and
again there's only one good move here
which card I can place it D captures on
c6 we have ECAP Terzani on f3 and now G
captures on f3 and this is the well
there were a lot of more or less
critical moments in the game but this is
the most critical moment in the game
where the only good move for Kramnik and
disposition is Queen captures on f3 and
after Queen captures rook captures now
King to e2 attacking the rook
black would have to give up the exchange
here as he doesn't want to allow seek
after some b7 so after rook captures
King captors and B captures on c6 black
would be up upon but and maybe with the
the bishop repair maybe he could hold
this position as he is up up upon but
it's a very hard to say would he be able
to but Romney didn't want to go into
this after G captures on f3 Kramnik
played the very brave rook captures on
f3 and rook captures an f3 is actually
losing on the spot but Kerrigan didn't
immediately punish this move you
immediately punish this move by playing
pawn captures on b7 but it's a really
complicated move to make in the in the
game Bishop to e2 was played by kurakin
as this immediately now wins the rook
you would you can't move the rook
otherwise you lose the Queen so it's
also a very nice move but if and he made
it like instantly if he played seek
after some b7 this wins the game
immediately but it's a very hard move to
make now we have to calculate Bishop
capture some b7 the rook captures on b7
and now basically we have two main lines
for black for you have to calculate what
happens if rook captures on f2 then you
have to see that King captures Bishop to
c5 check King moves now comes Luke to e8
check and after Bishop to e2 you have to
you have to calculate that everything is
fine here for white but that's not the
only thing after this rook captures on
b7 there's also rook to d8 and now
there's a double attack on the bishop on
d3 so after rook captures Bishop on e7
the rook captures on d3
Queen to b3 check now King to f8
attacking the rook on e7 now you have to
find the only move that wins for white
in this position and that rook to e6 in
route 36 is a is a very nice move it
completely wins the game for white
because that now there's not that no
defense against Queen to be a check
followed by Queen to e8 and this will be
checkmate when the King occupies the f7
square and the only way for black to do
anything about this as there's some no
defense against this is he could try
capturing an f2
and after if you captured and it's a bra
you can't allow Queen f3 check so King
to e1 and now again you have to see that
rook to d1 check of course now again if
you capture an f2 it's a draw
but after Queen captures now Egypt can
capture the Queen only one or you can
capture on e6 but whatever you do now
you can see that white is winning but
there are so many variations that white
has to calculate and circuit for some
reason didn't even want to spend any
time considering this
so after o captures and if I have three
he simply played Bishop to e2 now of
course you will lose that rook and
kramnik decided to immediately sacrifice
it would rock captures an f2 so King
captors on f2 and now Bishop to c5 would
check King to f1 and here Queen to f4
check you don't really have time for any
Queen to g3 ideas followed by Queen G to
check a queen f2 checkmate as Queen to
d5 check wins the game on the spot have
to remove the King Queen to d8 is coming
Bishop to d3 it's all over so after this
King to f1 move Queen to f4 check Bishop
to f3 and here again Kramnik took some
time to consider his next move
and he played B captures on c6 he missed
Bishop to e6 which is a slightly better
move but it doesn't matter because the
the same move the same defensive move
Kerrigan has to find for one idea works
also for the other ideas on short
Carrick and what I found it nevertheless
here B captures on c6 was played and now
Bishop to a6 is a threat and here the
only defensive move that still gives a
white an edge is actually Bishop to e1
and kurakin found this move if you try
and anything other than this for example
if you go King to g2
to immediately improve defender Bishop
and then maybe threaten Bishop - you
want to g3 then you lose the game on the
spot now Queen to g5 check King moves
Bishop trace X check King moves and rook
to e8 and it's all over you don't have
any squares for your King as the bishops
and the Queen are covering all of the
squares here so it have to
if we put a piece in there and then
simply rook captures and it's game over
so not a another completely you know
safe position but you do have to be very
careful so if this B captures on c6 Kirk
ended play the only move for white here
Bishop to e1 now Bishop to e6 was played
okay Bishop to h4 and this Bishop to h4
is again one of the ideas why this
Bishop to e1 move now the bishop from h4
will be very useful after the skin comes
to g2 it can come back to g3 but also
it's guarding the d8 square it's not
allowing kramnik to play rook to d8
followed by rook to d2 so here chronic
played rope to f8 we have King to g2
King to h8 now rook to c1 attacking the
bishop rock to f5 defending we have
rocked the c3 and it's a very critical
time in it's not a critical position but
it's a position where you feel that
white is under attack and black
definitely should have something but as
you can see he doesn't and Sergei really
plays a nice smoke rook to c3 improving
the position he still has his other work
to bring into the game but you know that
will happen and then he will simply be a
whole row cup so rook to d5 attacking
the Queen now you can see that the
rockin c3 is also post it can also be
used to play rook to d3 but kurakin
calculates correctly and he doesn't mind
Bishop captures Bishop captures this is
not with check but now this rook also
can interpose here this was a very
important idea of Rupe to c3 rook to f3
now Queen to g4 check Bishop to g3 now
you can see that the bishop is also very
useful and that diagonal
Bishop to d6 and now rook to h3
and although the White King is under
siege there's really no way for black to
increase the pressure here Bishop to e7
here Queen to e2 and now Mitchell blocks
Bishop to e4 Queen to F - now a5 a4 c5
chronic tries to push his best porn
Rock 2h one Bishop to f6 rook to e1
bishop moves to c6 now rook to e3 c4
Queen to e2 we have Queen to h5
capturing the pond on h5 Queen captures
on c4 and after Bishop to d7 here rook
to d3 was played and he in this position
Vladimir Kramnik resigned the game
basically he was only waiting for
hurricane to reach move 41 and to reach
time control and now there's really no
point in continuing this as kramnik is
down a hole rook and also done the
exchange so this is too much material to
have no compensation for but yeah it was
a very dangerous game Cromley decided
not to go for that worst ending or he
will be down the exchange so rather he
went for this attack featuring this rook
sacrifice an f2 and you know it could it
could have it could have happened if it
maybe wasn't wasn't Kirk in defending on
this side
for example if if Bishop to e1 wasn't
found here if any other move was played
then maybe chronics attack would would
have been successful but yeah it's very
hard to play like this in such a
tournament so unfortunately for Kramnik
another loss for him and another win for
Sergei Kerrigan who is now I don't have
the standings as there are still games
being played I think only the
Caruana Dingley run game is still being
played but yeah maybe I'll show that
game as well so and then I will show you
the standings but I think kurakin is up
to maybe even in the top three now after
winning this game so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it not not
the greatest tournament for Vladimir
Kramnik
and it's interesting he started with two
and a half out of three and now he's at
three and a half out of nine so a
brilliant start and then nothing for a
very long time but him you know who
knows he might play a couple of
brilliant games or all the way to till
the end of the tournament I will just
have to wait and see
so yeah I would like to think that that
was rife Alex I hope Daniel may a yearly
crucial and Eugene I avoid
for a contribution to my channel thank a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video cm for
watching and I will see you soon
probably tomorrow morning with game ten
of the Talbot UNIX series thank you